different already I read everybody knows
catch it
my name is Brittany and I am a high
school teacher my name is Brian and I'm
a middle school teacher I'm Jonathan and
I teach high school also just like
watching them spend for some reason I
see why kids love playing with them but
it's so distracting
just imagine hearing the noise for 15
minutes 22 times I just like um maybe I
just don't notice these things in the
same way but and I just think they're
cool okay like can I try that oh thanks
very good note of digital it does it man
you hearing this all day
you getting you this I think your book
to page oh I always wanted to like like
half of it I saw a double spinner I suck
that's prophetic wow it's Sunday oh
that's the thing how to be your backup
oh my god oh wow
now we know what you really do when you
get home yeah that's the easy one oh I
don't think that's a real thing happy
imagine students bring this to school
too
Oh what I'm actually getting entertained
by this we should start a class ah
[Music]
yeah you're just like under Oh Lu there
you go
oh it's so good that relaxes me I see
why the kids like it but should I give
Ben no way kind I just want to sit here
and keep doing that it's open oh cool I
mean I might even get my own and start
figuring out some traces and then show
you soon
and then show my sanity stuff and then
we can just do a whole lesson on dinners
ha ha ha my final thought just see what
are you gonna do with you
[Music]